hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from round four of the
video grand prix currently being played
in belgrade uh yesterday was a rest day
and now uh around five is currently
being played but this is one game that i
decided to show from round four uh all
the games ended in a draw in round four
uh except for this one that uh which may
or may not have ended in a draw you guys
will have to uh see what happened it's
alexandre pretty versus maxima sheila
grove and of course we will be having a
nice sicilian defense so here uh predk
opens with e4 we have c5 maxine goes for
the sicilian defense knight f3 d6 and
the open sicilian with d4 we have
captures captures knight to f6 knight to
c3 and of course as it's maxine playing
a6 the night or defense is on the board
and here the most popular way of meeting
the night of is bishop to g5 bishop to
a2 also extremely popular uh bishop to
g5 is considered the main line so here
we have e6 and now already
we go into some uh maybe uh not so much
explored uh uh territory here f4 and
queen to d2 are the main ideas but here
we have queen to f3 uh bishop to e7
continuing development and the now queen
side castle so white is playing very
rapidly uh developing all of the pieces
every piece uh is a developing move and
now white castle queen side white will
play king to b1 to make sure that his a2
pawn does not come under attack at some
point and it's going to be a a very very
enjoyable game so here queen to c7 is
what's usually played but again maxine
plays uh well
a very interesting idea queen to a5 so
already the bishop on g5 is hanging here
we have h4 defending the bishop and the
now bishop to d7 so this bishop is uh
hoping to at some point assume this
diagonal but before that happens we have
to play knight to c6 deal with the
knight on the e4 play b5 rook to c8 and
as usual hope to execute b for at just
the uh right exact moment and now uh
bishop to e2 and g4 are known ideas here
but here pretka plays bishop to c4 so
another move another developing move uh
and it's a maxim to play here so as i've
moved in this complete this position has
never been reached again uh and he
continues with knight to c6 just
developing
uh interestingly if you try b5 right
away and it seems like white really uh
is asking for this because he plays the
bishop on c4 so you know that b5 and b4
are coming with tempo uh e5 just wins
the game for white that's the idea
attacking the knight and the rook and
while this e5 advancement isn't
something new against the night of
usually black will solve everything by
just playing knight to d5 however here
with the inclusion of the bishop on c4
it just doesn't work because we captured
the knight now we're going to play e
captures on the e5 and now e captures on
d6 attacking the bishop even giving up
our g5 bishop
to drop with check and after captures
and captures i'll look at this position
now we have a beautiful passport on d6
where is the black king going not really
going queen side uh going king side with
the open h file or sam semi open file
for the rook and not great and staying
in the center that this would be
completely lost for black however you
play this so instead after bishop to c4
maxime just continues developing knight
to c6 and now
bishop back to b3 here the bishop is a
very nice defender of the queen side and
also assumes a beautiful diagonal so
here h6 maxim now asks so what do you do
with the bishop do you capture do you go
back and bishop the e3 also you might
consider because you can't play bishop
to f or e5 just uh is is bad uh but you
could capture on c6 and then put the
bishop on f4 however pretty decides to
play bishop to e3 and now knight to e5
attacking the queen queen back to e to
end the rook to c8 so you can see that
all of black's moves are pretty much
standard knight dorphin moves uh with
with b5 b4 uh incoming bishop will come
to c6 at some point uh and so on so here
king b1 nice prophylactic idea getting
away from the from the c file also the
king will add additional supports to the
a2 pawn and now finally b5
uh we have f4 now black gained the tempo
by uh chasing away the queen from f32
but now white wins it back now forces
the black knight to move knight eat the
g4 at challenging the bishop here and
now what do you do here uh it seems um
very unnatural to just give up your your
bishop pair but if you play something
like bishop to g1
then you are inviting b4 and now look at
this your knight has no squares and if
you try something like knight to d5
which is always a theme against the
sicilian uh when the king is still in
the center of the board here it just
doesn't work we're going to capture it
and now let's say e5 captures captures
now you actually give the piece back you
can just castle here and after captures
captures you get this position where
black is just so much better uh so
instead after this knight eat the g4
pretty plays e5 and it looks like a pawn
sacrifice but not really because the
queen is uh kind of x-raying that e5
square so you know that uh some
discoveries will be made so here d
captures on e5 f captures on e5 knight
captures on e5 and now bishop captures
on h6 opening up a discovery here but
this also uh brings a maximum rook into
the game right away so rook captures on
h6 queen captures on e5 and now we have
queen back to c7 offering a queen trade
uh notice that b5 for the b4 for the
moment is impossible because now the
queen here would be hanging so maxine
just offers a queen trade and he says um
of course whenever you play the sicilian
your your end game should be better than
white's end game if you know everything
is played out properly and i have the
bishop pair so my rook is already in the
open this rook is nicely placed on the
semi-open c file so it would be very
enjoyable for black so of course white
declines the trade
and you can see how the bishop here
very nicely guards the c-2 pawn so the
the queen isn't necessary here to guard
the c2 pawn but it's um
uh you know it's okay but at least your
knight can move now you can play some
like knight to the e4 and you don't have
to worry about the c2 pawn uh hanging so
here we have queen to f4 a nice active
move with the queen going after the h4
pawn and here how do you defend it it's
uh or do you even want to defend it uh
well you have to give up the pawn that's
the sad reality of the position so black
definitely wins upon here it's only a
matter of how you give it up and here
pretty
figures out a very interesting way of
giving it up he plays rook to h3 and for
the moment you can't really capture here
if you guys are you know thinking about
capturing an h4 that's definitely uh
another good idea because after rook
captures g3 just wins the game so
hopefully none of you were thinking that
so instead we have rook to c5 very nice
rook cliff the rook can now easily be
shifted into the attack and now rook to
e3 so
you can see that a lot of pressure is
being piled up here on that e6 pawn and
uh well for the moment it's being
defended by the bishop and the pawn but
it could go could go wrong if you're not
careful so here queen g4 maxime again
offers a queen trade and now knight to
f3 again now alexander declines the
trade and now finally bishop to c6 so
you can see how long maxim's bishop
waited on d7 for the knight to move away
from the defense of the c6 square and
now the light square bishop just assumes
this beautiful diagonal here we have a4
another a very nice trick
because uh it seems like you don't want
to open up the queen side because you
castled queen side but here capturing on
a4 is is very bad after queen captures
here uh now it's uh definitely white
who's better because if you take the
bishop this is just checkmate yeah you
have to block and then rook captures or
queen captures will be checkmate uh so
sorry after uh bishop d8 queen captures
will be checkmate so instead uh after a4
we have kinked f8 maxim just says all
right i can just make a nice
prophylactic move with the king now i
can block with the knight with the
bishop everything is perfectly fine now
my rook is on h6 so it's not like i'm
castling anytime soon so here are a
captures on b5 a captures on b5 and now
g3
uh defending the h4 pawn and kinda
offering the the g3 pawn uh but maxim
not interested in any of that maxim now
says all right now is the absolute
precise moment to execute b4 and now he
plays it pawn to b4 uh knight can come
to a4 or a2 but it doesn't really matter
because uh well it is just a terrible
position for whites and very difficult
to play so knight to 82 kind of makes
sense it's which tempo you are attacking
the b4 pawn but now comes rook to f5
defending b4 and also a triple attack
here on the knight on f3 so knight to d4
you really have nothing better you have
to offer a queen trade now and finally
maxime gets his queen trade queen
captures rook captures and now bishop to
f3 uh
uh
uh scoring the rook here of course one
will be one will be lost but this is
kind of what predk uh was going for uh
because now what do you play if you
capture with the knight which of course
can be played then rook captures on f3
and this is uh close to lost for white
so the g3 pawn is hanging and there's
just no good way to defend it if rook g1
we're going to attack it again and if
you defend it again let's say bishop c5
chases away the rook and of course we're
going to win this easily so instead
finds a very interesting move that is
great unless maxine plays it to absolute
perfection and we finally reach the
position from the thumbnail and that is
rook captures on e6 and it seems like
okay
you can capture this rook you can
capture this rook so it's basically your
choice luckily for maxine both of these
moves are are winning for black but it's
hard to hard to
know this for for sure if you don't
calculate it precisely so here maxine
plays bishop captures on d1 and now
comes the idea now not knight captures
on f5 because if you go for this then we
just captured the rook and after this
rook is captured on h6 g captures bishop
characters on e6 you can quickly see
that black is just up a piece so of
course we can't play this now comes the
idea behind rook captures on e6 after
maximum capture then d1 rook captures on
e7 and this is the uh
the the poison that alexander brought to
the table uh and the position is
perfectly fine unless you play one very
precise move
for maxine so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this incredible
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not doing anything
weird like capturing the rook and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is bishop captures and c2 with
check that's the move that's the only
move that wins the game for maxime and
now white's entire position just falls
apart but just in case you guys are
wondering if you capture the rook then
this rook falls with check once you move
the king then we're gonna capture this
rook as well and after let's say
captures knight captures on b4 and now
you get this position where okay it's
bishop and knight against the bishop at
night but white is up two pawns of
course it's completely winning for white
however after bishop captures in c2
check both king and bishop characters
are just terrible and uh well moving the
king doesn't help as this rook has now
access to f1 and the bishop left the
back rank so here uh what could you do
you could capture with the bishop but if
you capture with the bishop then again
rook f1 check and after knight to c1
blocking now king captures an e7 and now
you don't have to worry about
losing this rook with a fork and even if
a fork happens you will very gladly just
give up the rook knight captures g
captures and after all is said and done
it's still uh
you are up the exchange same amount of
pawns so completely winning for black so
instead after bishop captures on c2 king
captures and c2 was played and now how
do you win this of course rook to c5
would check we have to move the rook
away from being captured uh
you know what can white play king to d3
was played not just king captures on e7
and here okay now the knight f5 is is
impossible because the bishop no longer
covers that square so we play knight
captures on b4 but not just knight to d7
and now white will of course try
everything because you will try and play
it out until the end maybe maxine makes
some sort of a mistake but you are up
not by one exchange but by two exchanges
so here at knight d5 check king to f8
now comes knight to f5 and of course
we're gonna move the rook g6 put
pressure on the g3 pawn knight to d to
e3 and now rook to b6
attacking the bishop if the bishop moves
of course we pick up the pawn so knight
d4 defending the bishop now knight to e5
with check king e4 knight to c6 now
going for trades because absolutely
every trade now is favorable for black
bishop to d5 and now knight to e7 again
attacking the bishop so here we're going
to play b3 and maxime not in a rush to
trade everything off even though it's
perfectly fine uh there are still a
couple of more precise moves to be
played rook g6 goes after the pawn b for
now challenges the rook now rook to c3
we have bishop to c4 and now uh
or instead of bishop to c4 you could try
knight d to f5 uh to defend it like this
but then we just trade of course knight
captures knight captures and after rook
g4 look at the rooks here controlling
everything you have to play king e5 rook
captures on b4 and of course again it is
just
everything is winning for black so
instead bishop c4 was played but now
rook captures on g3 you have to give up
one of the pawns be it g3 or b4 knight
to d to c2 and here maxine just played
rook to g for check and it was in this
position on mu 44 that alexander pretka
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here if you go up the
board king e5 we're just going to
capture here on c4 after knight captures
through captures we're up a full rook uh
and going for knight captures and g4
doesn't help because now just rook
captures on c4 and after the night
blocks we're gonna capture on b4 and
again a rook and knight uh uh and two
pawns will beat two knights and the pawn
and okay i know what you guys are
thinking but it's two nights nights are
often tricky bastards uh something good
might happen well that's possible it's a
classical game a time control has been
reached so uh pretka does not have any
hopes of of maksim messing this up if
you have this position in a blitz or
bullet game of course you play this
there's no resigning this
uh so yeah that's the game uh from round
four of the video grand prix currently
being uh played in belgrade hope you
guys enjoyed it a very nice display of
why maxime is one of the strongest
sicilian night of players in the world i
i mean it's just uh and they reached an
equalish position but maxine just knew a
lot more about the secrets uh you know
uh that it holds uh that than threat and
well it just quickly uh turned to his um
uh favor
uh so i hope you guys enjoyed that uh i
would like to thank gregory everyone
who's helping ukraine you from buying
from closebox.com congrats uh on the new
job elizabeth
and greetings for azravko boos for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
video grand prix until it ends so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day